[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans l'entretien
sur france24 notre invité aujourd'hui et
alain werner heel est avocat suisse et
il est à la tête de civitas maxima qui
est une organisation non gouvernementale
qui documente les crimes internationaux
et soutien les recours des victimes
il est avec nous depuis genève merci
bonjour
votre travail est un travail de longue
haleine de patience de persévérance
vous êtes surtout penché sur les crimes
commis en sierra leone et au liberia
dans les années
1990 alors c'est un travail qui remonte
à loin mais qui semble en tout cas porté
ses fruits il y a plusieurs procédures
en cours aux états unis en suisse
royaume uni en belgique en finlande et
même ici en france pourquoi est-ce que
vous pensez que c'est si important de
faire ce travail aujourd'hui
à écouter la pensée les simples la la
demande n'est pas venu de nous soutenons
pas des avocats européens qui ont voulu
travailler là-dessus vraiment moi j'ai
travaillé pendant cinq ans pour le
tribunal spécial pour la sierra leone
dans les années 2000 et j'ai pu voir que
s'il ya eu un tribunal ancien rénale un
tribunal international et bien albi la
côte et le libéria avec une guerre qui
s'est déroulé de façon assez en
parallèle à la guerre de sierra leone
également entre 200 et 300 mille
victimes pour cette guerre civile eh
bien il ait eu aucune justice aucune
justice aujourd'hui au liberia la
communauté internationale a failli à
mettre sur pied un tribunal
international vous vous rappelez qu'a eu
quand même une prix nobel de la paix
première présidente
d'afrique qui a été libérienne
présidente ellen sirleaf johnson et il
serait un passé donc est victime
évidemment comme il ne se passe rien au
liberia est bonne je cherchais à pouvoir
obtenir justice ailleurs et c'est comme
ça que en collaboration avec des
libériens une organisation libérienne
monrovia et maintenant commencer à
travailler comme vous l'avez dit en 2012
avec des résultats et je crois que c'est
un modèle qui est porteur d'espoir
possiblement pour d'autres victimes
alors il y a eu en juin 2021 une
décision sans doute historique un
tribunal suisse a condamné un chef de
guerre libérien a lieu coscia à 20 ans
de réclusion pour crimes de guerre c'est
la peine maximale
en quoi est-ce que c'est historique est
ce que c'est avant tout pour l'histoire
pénale ou est-ce que c'est avant tout
historique pour les victimes
à l'écouter c'est je pense que c'est
historique effectivement à double titre
saleh pour les victimes parce
qu'effectivement c'est la première fois
dans l'histoire du liberia qu'un chef de
milice quant aux commandes on est
condamnés pour des crimes de guerre
commis au libéria donc c'est une toute
première comme vous l'avez dit il y
avait des procédures aux états unis il y
avait eu en 2017 en 2018 et
condamnations à philadelphie contre des
gens qui avaient été parquées partie de
la guerre au liberia mais c'était pour
des crimes en immigration donc il y
avait jamais eu encore une condamnation
pour crimes de guerre contre un libérien
est donc évidemment pour les victimes
qui sont venus deux libérés a jusqu à
bellinzone dans la partie suisse italien
de la suisse pour porter la parole lors
parole et dire ce qu'ils avaient subi
c'était évidemment historique ça l'est
aussi de façon incidente mais c'est
quand même évidemment important pour la
suisse allait aussi pour la suisse parce
que rendez vous compte que cette
condamnation devant le tribunal pénal
fédéral est la première devant cette
instance pour crimes de guerre donc en
fait ça a été historique et pour le
libéria et pour les victimes liberia et
également pour l'histoire juridique en
suisse alors comme je lé deal il ya
plusieurs autres procédures en cours il
ya un procès qui doit d'ailleurs
s'ouvrir cette année normalement
en france qui est liée au liberia ce
n'est pas exactement le même profil mais
mais ça ça y ressemble
est ce que en france vous pensez que
pour le liberia mais aussi peut-être
pour des crimes commis ailleurs il y a
dorénavant un terrain favorable a bien
entendu alors effectivement comme vous
l'avez dit il y aura un procès en cour
d'assises en france du 10 octobre au 4
novembre pendant quatre semaines d'un
chef de milice qui étaient de la même
faction juli mot kallio chat qui sera
acquis a été renvoyé en procès pour
notamment crimes contre l'humanité il y
aura comme ça s'est passé en suisse des
victimes qui vont venir du liberia pour
témoigner durant ce procès est un procès
très très important et pour nous qui
travaillons tous partout dans le monde à
la recherche des juridictions au nom des
victimes lorsque comme c'est
malheureusement souvent le cas il peut
pas y avoir deux justices là où les
crimes ont été commis parce
qu'évidemment tout le monde est d'accord
que d'abord il faut qu'il y ait justice
là où les crimes ont été commis
si c'est possible malheureusement
souvent c'est pas possible et donc les
victimes sur ces justice et la france
doit vraiment être fier à mon avis de ce
qui se passe chez vous au niveau de ces
crimes internationaux parce que bien sûr
tout le monde est au courant il ya eu
plusieurs procédures rwandaise il ya
cette procédure libériennes qui arrive
qui ça je crois à la première en dehors
des procédures ou en date mais il ya
beaucoup d'affaires qui sont en enquête
chez vous de beaucoup beaucoup
d'affaires dont beaucoup de pays et pas
seulement en afrique je pense
qu'aujourd'hui possiblement avec
l'allemagne avec la hollande la france
est un des pays où ces procédures
peuvent exister et où il se passe des
choses et des moyens sont donnés aux
enquêteurs aux magistrats aux procureurs
pour travailler alors on va venir à une
procédure sur un autre pays qui a lieu
en allemagne mais d'abord je veux quand
même revenir sur le libéria le liberia
célèbre au moment où
on se parle son bicentenaire il y avait
eu des promesses de poursuite de cour
spéciale le président de george weah
l'avait même promis lors de sa
réélection mais on a l'impression comme
ailleurs peut-être que finalement la
recherche de la paix l'a emporté sur
celle de la justice parce qu'on sait
qu'il ya certains anciens chefs de
guerre qui sont aujourd'hui au coeur du
pouvoir
exactement exactement vous avez
absolument raison il ya une commission
réconciliation vérité au liberia donc ça
c'est vraiment un mécanisme a été mis
sur pied complètement libérien après les
accords de paix et après la fin de la
guerre pour faire des recommandations
elle fait ses recommandations en 2009
tout à fait explicitement même avec des
listes de gens qui devaient être jugés
elle demande à ce que des procès
criminel pour les crimes de guerre pour
les crimes contre l'humanité pendant la
guerre soient intentées au libéria et
vous êtes la plus de dix ans après avec
effectivement aucun effort aujourd'hui
mais je pense que la pression a
considérablement augmenté moi je me
rappelle qu'on a travaillé commencé à
travailler en 2012 2013 2014 c'était
quasi l'omerta personne n'en parlait
c'était même presque dangereux d'aborder
ce sujet et grâce à ces procédures vous
avez mentionné en france vous avez
mentionné en suisse aux états unis il ya
un procès qu'a lieu en finlande on
attend le verdict dans deux semaines et
la cour finlandaise rendez vous compte
s'est rendue au liberia et en sierra
leone l'année passée avec les juges les
avocats de la défense les procureurs ils
ont été pendant des semaines au libéria
pour entendre des témoins donc tout ça
crée évidemment
un élan et la société civile s'est
engouffré au liberia dans ses talents
pour dire non mais comment se fait-il
qu'il ya des procès sur des crimes
commis dans notre pays quasi partout
dans le monde maintenant et qu'il se
passe bien dans le pays donc si vous
voulez vous avez absolument raison sur
le constat est bien sûr on peut le
regretter et vous avez parfaitement dit
les enfants expliciter les raisons
lesquels cela se passe à savoir des
anciens chefs
de rebelles à très haut niveau qui sont
aujourd'hui de la politique au liberia
mais je pense que grâce à ces élans qui
sont vraiment des élans civique qui sont
des élans de victimes qui sont avec des
avocats qui sont avec des enquêteurs sur
le terrain et qui permettent d'obtenir
justice mais qui permet aussi de créer
cet élan au libéria pour demander la
justice c'est un peu ce qu'on a vu
notamment au chili après laffaire
pinochet ou au bout du compte même si
juridiquement les victimes avec gagner
pour copiner chez ceux renvoyés en
espagne l'a pas été pour des raisons
politiques non pêche que ça crée ensuite
je pense que ça discutable aujourd'hui
un mouvement au chili va la justice et
c'est là où ce modèle est intéressant
alors je veux en venir une procédure en
allemagne en janvier un ancien colonel
des services de renseignements syriens a
été condamné par la justice à la prison
à vie pour crime contre l'humanité alors
c'est le premier procès au monde un lieu
aux exactions attribuées au régime de
bachar al assad au liberia et en sierra
leone on parle d'ancien régime là on
parle d'une condamnation pour un régime
qui est au pouvoir en quoi est ce que
c'est important
ou peut-être c'est un espoir vain
ah non alors je pense que c'est
absolument pas un espoir vain hélas de
nouveau ce est un cas d'école merci
d'avoir posé cette question sur la syrie
parce que si vous y pensez
après tout les historiens sont d'accord
plus d'un demi million de victimes de ce
conflit d abomination autant qu'on
puisse y penser et une faillite absolue
de la communauté nationale et
internationale qui a été complètement
incapable jusqu'à aujourd'hui
de mettre sur pied un mécanisme qui pour
aurait pu permettre des procès et des
poursuites la cour pénale internationale
complètement paralysée notamment par des
veto au conseil de sécurité
évidemment la syrie n'a pas ratifié le
statut de rome alors il se passe des
choses aux nations unies mentionnez
parce que c'est important et l'une
d'entre elles est à genève les nations
unies ont réussi malgré tout à mettre un
mécanisme dont enquête qui est basé ici
à genève qui gardent les profs donc une
espèce de premier étage d'une possible
fusil un jour qui serait un tribunal
mais malgré tout il n'y a pas pour
l'instant encore une fois au niveau des
cours international rien ne se passe
dans la série et l'a de nouveau c'est
cette compétence universelle c'est cette
justice devant les cours nationales qui
permet d'avancer les choses vous avez
mentionné l'allemagne mais remarquable à
l'instar de la france qui fait beaucoup
d'efforts l'allemagne remarquable avec
effectivement cette ce procès enfin ce
jugement historique en janvier mais
également l'année passée il s'est passé
beaucoup de choses en allemagne donc
plusieurs recours régionales allemandes
sur les crimes commis par les nazis il
ya une phonation hambourg une
condamnation à munich et une
condamnation à francfort notamment pour
génocide d'un irakien qui avait acheté
une esclave et dont la fille de 5 ans
était morte enchaînés sous le soleil la
petite a fini par mourir d'épuisement et
et du seuil donc tout ça c'est des
choses qui se sont passées et
effectivement c'était en janvier et
alors là c'est un espoir je pense inouïe
pour les victimes quelqu'un qui était
très important dans les régimes
at hamas et qui a été comme vous l'avez
dit condamner je pense que évidemment
pourrait regretter comme que cela se
passe d'une certaine façon mais vu que
rien d'autre ce pas je pense que c'est
un espoir absolument fantastique pour
les victimes et je pense que ces
procédures vont se multiplier en
allemagne et ailleurs dayori aussi des
procédures en france gagné en suisse il
y en a beaucoup d'autres pays je pense
que cela va se multiplier et on l'espère
évidemment tous un jour ça amènera
finalement au-delà des blocages
politiques à une cour internationale
pour juger les crimes si nombreux qui se
sont produits en série alain werner
merci beaucoup d'avoir été avec nous
depuis genève
merci à vous d'avoir suivi cet entretien
sur nos antennes restez-y pour plus
d'informations
[Musique]